könntest du ganz allgemein egal wieo
einen Menschen töten ich muss
[Musik]
sagen servus es Kids und herzlich
Willkommen zu ich muss in die Linse
gucken nein herzlich Willkommen zu dem
ersten Q&A dass ich mache mit meinem
neuen Spielzeug und zwar der Ken leger
Mini x Kanon die hab mir
bestellt und wir befinden uns gerade in
meinem Bett und ich begrüße Sie sehr
herzlich zu einer Runde im Bett mit
es ja da kann man so schöne Sachen mit
machen die ganze Zeit rumkippen und ich
habe hier ein
Mobilfon das Wort gibt's nicht sondern
ein Mobiltelefon ja dass ich jetzt mein
Flugmodus packe damit garantiert
keine ihr wisst schon Interferenzen gibt
keine
Störgeräusche ich bin nicht so geübt im
Umgang mit diesem Ding hier und ich
schaue die ganze Zeit auf Bildschirm was
ich nicht machen sollte aber es
verleitet dazu weil man sieht sich
selbst hier da ist man selbst da oben
okay lass uns einfach mal losen denn ihr
habt ja alle eingeschaltet um zu sehen
was in meinem Bett so alles passiert und
dann gucken wir einfach was passiert ne
ich habe die Fragen hier auf meinem
Handy ich habe Twitter gar nicht
installiert es geht irgendwie auch über
den Browser keine Ahnung warum feiern
oder chilligen Abend zu
Hause hängt davon ab normalerweise gehe
ich schon gern feiern
aber würde ich hängt alles davon ab mit
wem man den Armen zu Hause verbringen
kann so ganz alleine chillen muss auch
nicht immer sein aber ich muss auch
nicht immer feiern gehen meistens ma ich
trotzdem mach ich trotzdem weil
irgendwelche Leute mich mitnehmen sagen
hey du lassen uns gehen komm wir gehen
schnell nächste Frage würdest du
irgendwann mal nach Köln ziehen ja mega
gerne eigentlich ich feier Köln
eigentlich ihr merkt schon meine Stimme
ist heute bisschen bisschen im Popo ne
übrigens wenn alles funktioniert wirürd
es heute me allererstes eins geht so das
die ein ja das die Z die D 4 5 mein
allererstes
Video mit 1 in 1080p ja in Full HD wenn
die Kamera dann in diese Auflösung
aufnimmt kurz bewegen kann man so toll
spielen hier habt ihr gerade gesehen was
da durch Bild gehuscht ist
eine lemone denn ich werde euch heute
vielleicht wenn sich die Situation noch
ergibt noch demonstrieren was eine
lemonenzitze ist ja alle Leute die sch
immer gefragt haben was ist eiglich
lemonenzitze das ma ich heute vielleicht
noch wir werden sehen ich würde echt
gerne mal nach Köln ziehen ja also ich
feier Köln eigentlich sind mega viele
Leute da die man so bisschen kennt schon
mal kennengelernt hat und es werden
wahrscheinlich immer mehr nach Köln
ziehen so deswegen würde ich eigentlich
feiern aber mittlerweile bin ich auch
nicht mehr so krass auf dem Trip dass
ich unbedingt unbedingt nach Köln will
ich feier die Stadt nach wie vor aber
ich weiß auch zu schätzen was ich hier
habe bei
[Musik]
mir wenn du dein Leben nur noch in einem
Land leben könntest welches wäre es boah
das ist eine schwierige Frage ich habe
immer so bisschen Schwierigkeiten mit
diesen endgültigen Antworten oder
endgültigen Entscheidungen muss ich
sagen ich war ja schon
im Ausland so ich war ja mal in in Asien
war ich schon ich war schon in Spanien
und deswegen weiß ich wie es in anderen
Ländern ist und weißt es auch zu
schätzen wie es hier in Deutschland ist
und es gibt viele Dinge die man da
vermisst die man hier hat z.B das
Klacken vom iPhone das vermiss ich immer
sehr im Ausland das klackt da nämlich
nicht darf es nicht nein so Ordnung
irgendwie das sowas sowas wie ein so
soziales Netz gibt mehr oder weniger
dass Leute eben einen nicht komplett
außer Acht lassen wenn man wenn es einem
irgendwi mal schlecht geht so wisst ihr
was ich meine z.B da da wo ich in Asien
war da ist ist einfach so da bist du
einfach weg ja wenn wenn irgendjemand
wenn du mal krank wirst und keine
Familie hast die sich um dich kümmert
die Leute lassen dich auf der Straße
liegen ist halt heftig ne also
vielleicht eher schon Deutschland
oderaniaania Spanien würde ich auch na
Spanien warum nicht Spanien wie gesagt
ihr merkt schon ich kann keine Antwort
geben mal drauf ich
bin oh man sieht mein Schatten hinter
mir und man muss mindestens einmal durch
die Haare
Pfeifen ich will jetzt durch die Haare
Pfeifen Leute
[Musik]
das funktioniert versucht versucht ihr
zu Hause mal euch durch die Haare zu
feilen ist nicht so leicht ja es ist
leicht gesagt Pfeifen durch die Haare
aber es ist harte Arbeit denkst du dass
man auch ohne Kontakt zu größeren
Youtubern noch was erreichen kann guter
Punkt gute Frage die mich jetzt gerade
auch so ein bisschen beschäftigt weil
was ich auch noch sagen wollte jetzt
endgültig für alle ich habe es leider
nicht in varo 2 geschafft und wenn ich
so sehe welche Leute dann doch in varo 2
drin sind
währenddessen ich es nicht geschafft
habe sieht man schon klar dass alles
geht alles um connections nur also Leute
die lange nicht so solange wie ich auf
Youtube sind oder so ich bin jetzt auch
nicht ewig dabei weiß Gott nicht aber
halt schon bald ein Jahr Leute die halt
lange
nicht viel kürzer dabei sind aber jetzt
irgendwie super connections haben und
keine Ahnung oder nicht mal ein
richtigen Minecraft Channel haben
so keine Ahnung ich will auch niemanden
irgendwie schlecht reden oder so aber es
ist halt schon alles connection ist
einfach so alles ander qu un möglich
gibt viel zu viele Channels als dass man
einfach so durchkommen könnte oder sich
über was halten könnte oder sich
entwickeln könnte ohne Leute zu kennen
es geht davon nicht welchen Song hörst
du am meisten momentan höre
ich am meisten würde ich sagen Action
bronsen das ist so ein Rapper aus aus
New York so ein dicker weißer Rapper
eigentlich mega witzig der Typ ich
verlinke euch mal das Lied das ist
glaube
ich wie heißt es comeup von Action
Bronson heißt das und das S ich
eigentlich gerade am meisten ja das ist
das nächste Frage gute Frage ich will
eiglich mehr Biss mehr rumt hier mit
diesem Ding
turn kann ich meinin mein Kopf nein kann
ich
nichtot hier wenn man so liegt ist die
Stimme komplett anders müsst ihr wissen
ganz andere
Stimme man kann so coole Sachen mit
dieser Kamera machen ne unfassbar sind
Fantreffen geplant momentan nicht nee
das machenich immer spontan also wir
sagen so keine wir sind jetzt in
Köln nicht
ersticken wir sind jetzt in Köln und
sagen dann
jo kommt mal vorbei kommt dahin und da
kommt meistens keiner weil es dann doch
zu spontan war und nachts irgendwie
hammerhart fähst du Longboard Punk Punk
nein er gibt sich selbst die Antwort
cooler dude er hat auf jeden Fall schon
erfasst ne ich war kein Longboard ich
war Auto
autisel und sonst nichts und Fahrrad
manchmal wenn ich nicht wenn ich wenn
Auto mir wieder zu teuer ist weil der
Sprit ist ein hen sage ich euch teuer
und ich wieder die ganze Zeit aufs
Display hammerhart ich hoffe mal das
Mikro ist jetzt nicht
zu zu sensitiv eingestellt also zu
empfindlich auf die mikrofonsensitivität
ist passend ah hier ist noch eine Frage
die finde ich auch mega geil könntest du
ganz allgemein egal wieso einen Menschen
töten und klingt creepy aber würde mich
bei dir echt mal interessieren wieso bei
mir bin ich so ein Mörder oder wie aber
ich muss sagen ich
Zweifelsfall Kön ich es mir schon
vorstellen also wenn wenn jemand
irgendwas ultra krasses macht wenn
jemand selber irgendwie einen aus meiner
Familie umbringt oder so dann keine
Ahnung klar wenn man jemanden umbringt
hat man sein Leben verkackt das ist so
aber trotzdem irgendwie ist es so diese
innere Gerechtigkeitsgefühl dass dann
einem sagt der muss jetzt auch drauf
gehen also ich würd es also ich würde
eher sagen eher ja obwohl ich jetzt weiß
Gott kein allzu gewaltbereiter
eskalieren der Mensch bin bist du gegen
irgendwas allergisch nein außer gegen
Bullshit allergic to
Bullshit dies kam die verleid ein so
dazu irgendwie eine Scheiße zu machen
irende
so ESI fragt meine Frage ist auf einer
Skala von ein bis Z zu bis ze bis ze
eins bis obs Z wie süß bist du und wie
süß bin ich also ich gebe sui
eine sech und ich gebe mir selbst eine
vier und John joh hat das nicht gesagt
John joh hat gesagt tut den Film zu ein
Film und das ist die oberste Regel wenn
Film machen wollt Leute welche Musik
hörst du so momentan wie gesagt sehr
viel Action bronen und natürlich auch
diesen einen ske fkop heißt das so so
ein Typ der so Mixes macht auf
Soundcloud der ist mega gut den habe ich
auch manchmal in meinen Livestreams
laufen ich kann euch die beid mal
verlinken also erster Link Action bronon
come zweiter Link das neue mixtap von
dem was ich auch gerade richtig Feier
immer so richtig asozial im Auto voll
aufdrehen wenn ich in die Uni fahre oder
so dann Push ich mich damit dann geht's
nämlich ab dann geht's R R ich habe gar
nicht die Namen vorgelesen Leute Scheiße
tut mir leid wir werden wie gesagt ich
bin noch nicht so in der Q&A Routine
drin wir werden auf jeden Fall noch mal
ein Q&A machen wenn es euch den gefällt
könnt jetzt schon mal Daumen nach oben
da lassen das Video neigt sich dem Ende
zu aber bleibt noch bis zum Schluss
jetzt kommt die Mörder überkrasse
oberhammerfage von jetzt sage ich den
Namen hat das privil als Letzter der
vorgelesen wird elrix Gaming LP wurdest
du schon mal von Fans
angesprochen ja ist schon mir schon mal
passiert und zwar glaube zweimal hier wo
ich wohne zweimal einmal irgendwie auf
der klar auf der Gamescom WoT nicht
gamescom sonder auf den vide days aber
das ist K s überall irwche Youtube Fans
aber das habe mich echt gewundert auf
Video so Leute wenn dieses kleine Q
gefallen hat dann las mal Daumen nach
oben da ich werde das jetzt für euch
irgendwie zusammenkutten so dass da was
cooles bei rauskommt und ich hoffe dass
wir noch richtig viel Spaß mit dieser
Kamera haben werden denn ich habe ich
habe mega viel Bock auf das Teil ich
feier das
extrem das ist eine lemone das ist eine
Zitze wenn man das zusammen tut ist das
eine
lemonzitze Spitze ja wie gesagt lass ein
Daumen nach oben da wenn es euch
gefallen hat ihr könnt gerne Ideen für
solche gedrehten Vlogs mal in die
Kommentare schreiben seid da kreativ lst
ich irgendwas behindertes einfallen wie
ihr Bock habt nur sag sagt nicht sowas
wie ein Porno weil am Ende mache ich es
dann doch und dann wird mein Channel
gestrike wegen euch also hau sie rein
macht's gut bis zum nächsten Video
und